or we get started this video is brought
to you by Squarespace I really
appreciate Squarespace sponsoring this
video a little later in this video I'm
going to tell you how you can save 10%
but first we have a review to do
[Music]
Breaking Bad El Camino or Breaking Bad
presents El Camino or just El Camino
point is El Camino is the Breaking Bad
movie we didn't know we needed but after
watching it we kind of did and I'm
surprised I didn't think of it sooner
this is the story of Jesse Pinkman and
what happened after he got alright
spoilers for Breaking Bad
no Camino not gonna spoil that but
Breaking Bad if you haven't seen
Breaking Bad yet I'm just saying at the
end of Breaking Bad you should have seen
it by now Jesse Pinkman gets away and we
were just supposed to be like oh I guess
Jesse Pinkman gets away so now we see
what happened with Jesse Pinkman as he's
trying to get away and Aaron Paul's
great in this he's great in this movie
he was great in the show it's like he
got better as the show went on he has a
great arc in the show that this movie
does it carries forward it's like now he
still has an arc he has more to give and
the movie has really intense moments
these are things it has everything
you've come to expect from a vince
gilligan Breaking Bad project it shot
well has great cinematography a couple
of neat musical sequences musical
montage is necessary and Breaking Bad
you watch this movie you know it's from
the mind of Breaking Bad I was surprised
it actually it does bounce back a little
bit it shows a little bit of the past
didn't expect that I expected it to just
go forward like I'm not gonna get into
specifics or anything like that but one
of the flashbacks it's like a hangout
day which it has to do because it has a
show alright will this happen and that's
why he's doing this other thing now in
the present time but it's a hangout day
and [ __ ] that hangout day I would rather
watch porn with my mom sitting next to
me and have her audibly tell me what's
happening on screen as I'm watching it
then have that day what I really
appreciate it it doesn't feel like it
was an afterthought this feels like a
thing that just didn't fit in with the
show and then he started better call
Saul he didn't really have time to put
it in Mary didn't have time to do this
in between that and better call Saul
Vince Gilligan the man who spent
Breaking Bad showing us everything
leaves a footprint everything matters
every little detail matters and they can
all come back
to haunt you vince gilligan the man who
even took time and better call Saul to
show us hey how much went into some
things in Breaking Bad keeping it vague
you should totally watch better call
Saul nothing is easy nothing just
happens and that guy told us yeah I
guess he just got away you know this
haunted him I feel like it haunted him
every night since Breaking Bad finish
like all right Walter White's Ark it's
done Mike Ehrmantraut done Saul blue in
back have we shown his beginning we're
showing his beginning we're even showing
where he ends up at the beginning of the
seasons but Jesse I guess just got away
you know that haunted him Walter White's
right hands doesn't just get away
there's a story there's a process
there's a lot that can happen he knew
there was more to tell and it really
does feel like yeah there was more to
tell Walter White cast such a huge
shadow over Breaking Bad it was the
right call if you had to choose to have
Walter white have it concentrate on him
Jesse took a bit of a backseat and now
we have his ending an ending that
doesn't really feel tacked on it may
seem a little late but better late than
never
what can I say my real regret is that
it's only two hours long I would have
liked to have seen this be like a
miniseries or something 6 episodes long
or something like that because in the
end El Camino it was great it started
out great you you're right into the
Breaking Bad world you have a little bit
of like where is it going why is it
doing that well you stick with it for
the journey and the journey completely
makes sense it never lost me it's shot
well looks great in 4k - I mean Netflix
streams and HD are your TV supports that
watch it looks good Aaron Paul is great
in it and most importantly it's grounded
in that realism that Breaking Bad was
always grounded in granite it's a
fantasy movie short fantasy show it
always
it's a fantasy universe but it has that
grit and has that realism which is this
is why we had to see what happened I
left the movie satisfied would it mean
as much if you haven't watched Breaking
Bad no you have to watch Breaking Bad if
you're gonna watch this you don't need
to watch this if you feel fulfilled with
Breaking Bad come over the more I think
about it after watching El Camino I feel
like I'm in lightens like now I know
when I watch the end of Breaking Bad
Jesse Pinkman smashes through the fence
so i ignorant ly just want to believe
that's the ending I can't and the fact
that I'm not willing to like if the
movie sucked
then I can just be like I don't know my
endings there but it doesn't suck
it's good so
now you have this attempt of breaking
bad now leads at Forks into this other
story and I personally think that's
really cool cuz that was my fear my fear
was that it was gonna feel really tacked
on unnecessary but the story's not
unnecessary it's a story worth telling
the story he deserves what would I write
this is tough it's it's a Netflix movie
that is springboarding off of a series
it's harder for me to write this one for
some reason while I think about it
though I'm so sure
and again this video is brought to you
by Squarespace Squarespace makes it easy
to build a website with a lot of great
looking templates you don't need
exhaustive experience in the fine art of
website building it's made for us we
common folk I appreciate that
Squarespace also lets you auto post
content from your website to Twitter
Tumblr Facebook and you can also
purchase domains directly from
Squarespace it's a digital world out
there an entrepreneurial world and I
personally appreciate something
user-friendly like this world's changing
time we change to hubs and I'm Carey
used to movie line you can try it out
for free and when you're ready click the
link below to squarespace.com slash
John's enter promo code John's upon
checkout you save yourself 10% off your
first domain purchase check it out try
it out thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video
all right decided this movie is worth
watching and worth buying in 4k I
imagine it'll come out in 4k eventually
it'll look good next to Breaking Bad
alright so El Camino have you seen it
what did you think about it did you
think it was necessary did it feel
tacked on for you or were you satisfied
with Jesse Pinkman getting his chapter
in the Breaking Bad universe whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]